お釈迦様がこのずっと無常説しますけど
あのマガダ国で あの南の方である村がありまして
そこであのバルマン人が
あの 畑やっていての今田んぼですね
バラモン人は結構金持ちな人です
畑 田んぼを耕してます
これでまあ牛百頭使って
ですからかなりの量ですね
牛百頭使って田んぼを耕してます
まあ大体あの田んぼの仕事をすると
まあ結構お祭りのような感じでやりますから
そちらにお釈迦様がこのその場所に托鉢に行ったんです
お祭りですからね まあいっぱいこのなんかいろいろ儀式やるし
まあ食べ物をたくさん作って
みんなで食べたりするし
まあ田んぼの仕事っていうのは
日本の神社の祭りような感じでね
まあかなり派手にやります
そうすると お釈迦様にしてみても
まあいっぱい食べ物あるところで
みんなあの集まってご飯食べたりするところだから
仕事をしながら まあそれ終わったらご飯食べるというところだから
たくさんご飯あるところでしょうし
まあそちらから少々ご飯もらいますよというこのことかもしれません
みんな一生懸命歌ったり踊ったり
まあ田んぼの仕事しているところにお釈迦様が何のことなく歩いて托鉢に来るんです
来たところで そのバラモンがお釈迦様そちらに待っているのを見てね
こういうことを言ってるんですね
アヤン・コウ・サマナ・カサミチャ・ワッカミチャ・カシットワジュ・ワピットワジュ・ブンダニ
サマナっていうのはシャモンというね
出家という単語であんまり敬語じゃないんですけど
サマンよ 私は田んぼを耕して種をまいて
それで食べているんだと
トワンキ・サマナ・カサスチャ・ワカストゥチャ・カシットワジュ・ワピットワジュ・ブンダス
あなたもどうですかね
自分で田んぼを耕して
種をまいて それでご飯食べたら？ということで
それはまあ明らかにお釈迦様にただで食うなよという話でもあるし
せっかく我々は仕事をして苦労してご飯食べているところに
あんたも自分で仕事を言って食べたらどうでしょうかと
いうことで まあご飯一皿あげるのはできてるみたいですね
そうするとお釈迦様が答えるんです
アハン・ピコ・グラフ・マナ・カサミチャ・ワッパーミチャ・カシットワジュ・ワピットワジュ・ブンジャーミ
お釈迦様は何のことなく
私も同じ単語でカシ・カサーミっていうのは
あの土を掘ることで耕すことですね
ワッパーミっていうのは
この種まくことですね
それで私も食べています
私もちゃんと耕すことをして
それから種まくことをして
それから食べています
で まあお釈迦様の智慧のところでしょうしね
だから私は田んぼを耕して食べてるんだから
あなたも仕事を田んぼを耕して仕事をして食べたらどうですと
私も田んぼちゃんと耕して食べてるんだよと
堂々と言うんです そうすると明らかにこの何言ってるのかっていうことはわからなくなるんですね
で 昔の習慣というのは
そうやってしょうっとわからないような何か言ったら
それはどういう意味でしょうかと聞くんです
だから出家ですから どうせどうしても土地持ってるわけではないし
自分が自分の田んぼで耕して食べてるんだったらね
托鉢に来るわけでもないし
なのに堂々と明らかに全く信じられないことを言うんです
全く信じられないことを言ったんだから
バラモンが何言ってるんでしょうか
この人は しかしこのバラモン人っていうのはすごい知識人ですよ
田んぼをやっていたんだからといって
ただの農白丁でも何でもないんです
バラモン人ですからね
ヒンドゥー教の生殖者でしょうし
金持ちだから連具と頼んで仕事をしてもらってるし
だからこの人は何か意味のある言葉を言ってるでしょうと
どう見てももう田んぼを耕すどころか何の話も意味もありません
ですからはっきりと聞くんですよ
あなた田んぼを耕している耕していると言ったっても
あのツキは見えませんし
他の道具もね 何一つも見えませんし
牛 牛 1匹もないでしょうと
田んぼを耕すために必要な道具何一つとない
それなのに自分ではちゃんと田んぼを耕して生活できると言いますよと
言われたらお釈迦様がそこで説明していくんですね
それで対話がそうやって迎えてしてあります
カッサコーパティジャナーシ
あなたは白鳥だと自分のことを言いますよと
しかし あなたは自分が農業をやっている人と言っても
あなたには農業に必要な道具一つもない
ですから あなたの農業に田んぼを耕すために必要な道具は何なのかと
何なのかと語りなさいと
言ったところで お釈迦様はこの瞬間で見事にこのそれ合わせてされるんです
サッダービージャンタポーウッティ
私はもうどちらの人も最初に必要なのは籾ですからね
田んぼの種必要でしょうし
土地というよりも大事なものはね
サッダービージャン このサッダー
信 確信というかね まあ理解していることをね
真理に対して自信あること
サッダーというのは信仰ですからね
その その信仰が私の種であると
タポーウッティ 修行することは努力すること
修行することが雨ですと
サッダーっていうのは
この仏教用語でサッダーっていうのは
ブッダの教えに対する教えを学んで納得することなんですね
ですから しっかりお釈迦様がおっしゃったことは確実にその通りらしいと
もう疑いはないんだと
で 知ることがサッダーであって
時々私に話しかけてくる人々は
まああの誰かの本を持ってきて
なんだかなんだらはんもうもうもうもうすごい人で
なんか仏教であんたが言ってること似てること言ってるんだよと
それでまあお釈迦様相手対比場がないんです
どうかな くだらな 誰かがもう似ていること似ていること誰でも言えますけどね
まあある意味腹が立って
だから私は今日から仏教徒で
その人の話を信じるんでしょうかと怒って言いましたけどね
長い間仏教学んでも やっぱり微塵でもブッダの教えに対する確信がないんですよ
それでみんなにも教えてあげようとしてるんだからね
だから自分ではっきり納得していない限りはね
仏教では信仰あるとは思わないです
あの人 私は今まで信じていたことと似ていることを言ってるんだと言ったってもね
それは信仰ができたってわけじゃないんです
とにかくあの真理に対する納得している
例えば四聖諦というものがありまして
4つの真理があります
それは学んで生きることは苦であると
渇愛があるんだから 苦はずっと続くんだよと
涅槃ということが唯一な救いの道である境地である
それには八正道という方法があるんだよっていうことはね
よくよく勉強して やっぱりこれしかないんだよと納得した人ならば
堂々と自信を持って仏教を語ることもできるんです
人が仏教に対してなんか反論したっても
いえ 違いますよと こういうわけで
こういうわけで あんたが言ってること違いますよと
お釈迦様が言ってることは正しい
正しいんだよと言えるんですね
だからそれが心にないないのと
それが種なんです 悟りというものを現れてくるために
それに修行するということは雨ですね
だから雨が降るんですよ
種に で 種が芽が出て まあ花咲きますからね
ヒリーイーサーマノーヨッタンサティメーパハラパーツナ
それからこのスカブドウォブのリスト化くるんですけど
これは日本語に訳はできないし
もう何言ってるか私にわかりませんし
パンニャーミーユガナンガラン
次に言うのはパンニャー智慧が私のユガナンガランっていうのは
このシンハラ語ありますけど
全然役に立ちません この訳は
そのまま言語を置くだけで
ユガナンガラン まあまあ
おそらくこのまああのすきを牛が引っ張るんだから
牛の首につけておかないと
そこそれとすきそのもの
その 2つなんですね それがこの私のあの智慧でした
まあ牛とすきですよ それが智慧であると
で 智慧がない だから智慧でもって田んぼが耕していくということで
ヒリーイーサーマノーヨッタン
これ牛を繋いでおかないとね
しっかりと それすごく大事なことなんですね
ヒリというあの こちらはヒリーイーサーと言って
あのすきのあの気にする部分が土を掘ってくれるところだと書いてますけど
それがヒリであって ヒリっていうのは恥ずかしいと思うことなんで
恥ずかしいというか 態度というかね
まあただ単に人間でいたっても
動物と何ら変わりのないし
ただ食べて年取って死ぬだけでしょうしね
こんなまあただ年とって食って死ぬんだ
それこそ人生だって言うから
それは恥ずかしいということでね
それから悪いことをするのもすごく恥ずかしいんだ
で 立派な人間でしょう
ですから人間ですから
しっかり頑張って成長しなくちゃいけないんだという
まあしっかりした態度を持つことでもあります
それがあるんだから 情けない惨めな人生は嫌やと
どんな立派な人間が生きていたっても
ただのそれはもう幻覚であって
立派じゃないんで 誰でも誰でも何か仕事をして食べて年取って死ぬだけの人生です
何一つ大事なことはしないんです
ですから もういい仕事をしているんだとか
そんなのはどうでもいいことで
私は弁護士だと言って
私は医者だと言って まあ自慢するほどことじゃないよ
ただの仕事でしょうと
それで世の中の人々あの人は政治家になりましたとかね
失敗になりましたとか
大臣になりましたとか
あからさまにとかね 成功したとかね
言うんだけど 何を何を成功しているのか何もないんですね
ただ自分が食べるために政治を選んだだけのことです
だからただ単にそうやって生きていることは
仏教ではあんまり評価してません
動物と大した変わりはないんでしょうし
動物には牛にならないといいんだから
牛になってないだけで
動物にも議員制度が議会制度が必要だったらちゃんと作りますよ
そんなどうったことはないんです
例えば群れでなければ生活できない動物はちゃんと群れを作ってるでしょうに
それちゃんと政治やってるでしょうに
必要な程度でやってますよ
誰でも 鳥たちも単独行動する鳥もいるし
群れで行動する鳥もいるし
単独行動する鳥にとっては単独行動でなければ食べられませんし
群れで行動する動物は群れで
鳥たちは群れでなくては生活できない
それで群れですごく仲良くやっているでしょうに
きちんとリーダーがいて
ちゃんと管理で だから政治システムというのは動物の中にもありますよ
議会は作ってない いらんだからね
そんなのは だから人間が優れているということは
人間だけの考え方で 私こそ世界一偉いやっていうことに何の変わりもないし
あんた世界のすべての人間調べたかというと
調べてないんだよと しかし私は世界一偉いでしょうということでしょう
人間よく言ったら 人間がすごく優れているんだとかね
ですから このヒリという恥ということが心にあると
その人は成長するんですね
そういうふうに生き方は恥ですよ
とりあえずそれで硬い土を掘ってくれるんです
で 土を掘ってもらわないと
ひっくり返してもらわないと
もう籾をまけませんからね
それで我々の硬い心 このムチな心
殻殻がすきで掘るような感じで自我を掘ってくれるんです
ものを酔った それで牛をしっかり縛っておかないと逃げられないようにと
あるいは鋤をなんとなくグラグラでつなげたっても
土を掘れません だいたいグラグラですけど
やってる人が自分の手でじーっと下に付けておくんです
それじゃあね 子供だったら乗ってるんです
そうするとすきがきちんと土の中に入り
泥の中に入りますからね
それで牛がそれを引っ張るんです
二頭二頭で引っ張る場合は
だいたいしっかり結んでおけばいいし
それでも誰かがすきをきちっと泥の中に付けておかないと
で そういうことでこの縛るロープが必要なんですね
それが心ですと だから自分の心はしっかりと縛っておいて
サティメーパーラパーチャラ
それからサティという気づきこと
パーラパーチャラというのは牛が動かないと脅さなくちゃいけないんですね
別に牛にとっては面白い作業じゃないでしょうに
嫌でしょうに そんなの
何のためにこれやらなくちゃいけないでしょうかと
全然わからないでしょう
ですから 強引に牛を引っ張ってもらわないと
牛はそこら辺にペタッと寝たいし
あるいは草やったらそれ食べて反芻しながら寝たいでしょ
それは牛の生活でしょう
で 鋤で土を掘るっていうのを何度言って全然わからないでしょうに
だから牛はいくら好きに絞って縛っておいても
牛は動きたくないんです
ですから 強引に動かさなくちゃいけないんです
というわけで 牛を踊るためにちゃんとスティックを持ってるんですよ
それはサティであると
サティっていうのはヴィパッサナー瞑想でこの実況中継させるということで
このサティの実践されてますね
気づきの実践されてるんですね
そこで妄想っていうのは
牛のようにただどこかで座り込んで反芻する
妄想することはそういうことだから
同じことを繰り返し繰り返し繰り返して
何年三年瞑想したっても
インタビューしたら同じこと言うんだからね
だから全然妄想に抗う必要ということを全くもやってない
ですから このそれはもう実況中継っていうのは簡単なことじゃない
これ心に対して脅しなんです
妄想したいんだけど 実況中継してるんだから
かなりもう脅しなんです
無知な心だから 動物次元を乗り越えたくないんだから
反芻しながらいたいんだからね
そういうことでもう実況中継させる
実況中継すると 当然真面目にやる人は
それはかなり心にとって自分にとってはこれは結構いじめだなとわかると思いますけど
かなりきついんだと これってかなりいじめられてるんではないかと
確かにそれで無知な心をいじめられてるんですよ
妄想させてさせてないんです
やりたいことをやらせないということは結構きついでしょうに
だからこのサティということがこのスティックですよ
牛に牛を脅すために それからカヤグットワチーグット
私は体で悪いことをしないで
体をきちんと制御している
それから言葉もきちんと制御している
体で言葉でいい加減なことをやると
サティの実践できないんですね
ですから 体はちゃんと制御して
言葉も制御して修行中は食べてはいけないんですね
だから食べるとサティの一片もなくなっちゃうんです
あるいは激しくあっち行ったりこっち行ったりしちゃうと
もう瞬間に心興奮してしまって
もうサマーディの全く大反対で
もう悪にもう染めてしまっちゃうんですね
活発ってわけじゃないんです
それはただ単に貪瞋痴に誘惑されて操られてるんですよ
貪瞋痴に操られてると結構人間は激しく動くんです
それは仏教で活発ってことじゃないんです
ですから 体もそれなりに動きすぎて感じなくちゃいけない
だから体と言葉を感じて制御しているんだと
いわゆる体で悪を犯さないし
言葉で悪を犯さないことで
アハーレウデレヤと食べる時でもお腹の量を見て食べる
量を知って適量というか少量を食べてるんだと
サッチャンカロミニッダーナ
これすごい難しいですね
それからこの何も矛盾のないように生き方をするんだということで
このサッチャンというのは真理
真理に基づいて生活しているんだと
で 私たちはすごい矛盾の人生ですよ
で 例えばがんですよとかね
それで混乱して ものすごい眠れなくなって
お薬飲んだりとかね よりいい病院に行かなくちゃいけないんだからということで
別な病院に行ったら そこでまた手術するにもものすごい半年
一年ぐらいかかるんだぞとかね
しかし 自分がすごくしっかり論理的にもののことを考えてるんだと
これは全部冗談でしょうと
だって人間なら病気になるんだぞ
死ぬんだぞということは事実です
それを認めたくないでしょうに
長生きしたいでしょ？死にたくはないでしょうと
それって理屈ですから
長生きしたい 死にたくないと思ったら時点で矛盾でしょうに
でもみんな堂々とそう思ってるでしょう
だから口先だけで まあまあまあそんなのはブッダ後ろまでもないんだよとかね
言っても 無常だとかね
これぐらいのことって
それって偉大な真理なのかとかね
そういう態度でしょう
無常ぐらいは我々もわかってるんだと
そういうのはもうそうじゃないでしょうし
これものすごくもう矛盾な生き方なんですね
無常だからわかってるんだったら
なんで些細なことにもうすっごく混乱するんですかね
例えば自分の家が火事になったと
自分の商売がもう倒産するはめになってるんだと
もし無常っていってるんだったら
そんな商売っていうのは倒産になるのは当たり前でしょうし
そうか そうなったのかっていうことで
なんであってはならない気持ちでやらないんですかね
認めたくないでしょう
だから人は矛盾で生きてる
言ってることと口で言ってることと実際の生き方っていうのはまるっきり別なんですよ
みんな個人っていうのを勘定で生きてるんです
だから理屈なんかは頭の中にもうそれでしろもので
全然育てない 何のため理屈を使うのかというと
人生に生きる生きる道を教えると
それに反論するために使うんですね
そんなのはもうわかってますよと
それってもう真っ向から相手を侮辱することなんですけど
そういうのに気づかないんです
そうわかってるんだったら
じゃあ問題ない あんたはもう幸福なもんだから
どうぞ帰ってくださいと言わなくちゃいけないんですね
ですから やっぱりこの人間っていうのは理屈で生きてるわけじゃない
一人一人 何のために勉強するものかと
全部役に立たない 勉強したものを知ったものは
この幸福の生き方に攻撃するために使うんです
嘘を言ってはいけないというと
あらゆるデータを持ってきて
この世の中ではもしかすると歴史家だったらもう歴史家のデータ持ってくるかもしれない
何さん何さん何さん これで嘘をついたのではないかとかね
これで世界支配したのではないかと
科学を学ぶで まあ心清らかにすることはもうバカにする
そんなのはやったって何の意味もないんだよ
科学世界ではあれだこれだと言ってるんだよとかね
人間はDNA だよとかね
あれは DNA の開発をというか
まあ解明して それによって道徳的な生き方をもう否定してやろうではないかと
だから結局は我々が勉強するものっていうのは
我々の自己破壊になるんであって
矛盾的な生き方を肯定するんであって
正しい道に導くことはないんです
だから勉強すればするほど修行はできないんですよ
論理的に生きているならば問題ないんですと
人を論理的だったら やっぱり嘘をついちゃうと
詐欺や法律で裁かれるし
みんなの信頼をなくなるし
情けないし 自分があやしいことをしているという証拠でしょうし
あやしいことをして商売するのは商売自体が安定しないでしょうに
怪しい商売だったら だったら論理的に考えれば
やっぱりもう嘘をついてはいけないんだ
怪しい商売で金儲かっている時点でもう嘘をついてるでしょうに
価値のない品物を価値のある品物として売ってるんだから
だから嘘を言わなかったら
もう嘘でコマーシャル作らなかったら売れませんよという理屈を持っている
それは理屈じゃないんですね
本当に理屈で生きてるなら問題ないんです
理屈で生きているならば
人間はちゃんと道徳を守って
戦争をしないで 戦いをしないで
お互い憎しみ合いをしないで生きているはずなんです
でも誰もそうやってないでしょうに
堂々と喧嘩する それで喧嘩を正当化するため
理屈を弄ぶ それ不法を正当化する
正当化するために だってその人は悪いんだと
悪いという何か証拠あるのかと
もうそれっていっぱいありますよ
ですから その人と喧嘩して裁くべきだろうと
逆に言えば あんたそれで楽しいでしょうかと
相手と喧嘩して相手相手に勝ってしまったところで
あんた幸福になるのかというと
そうならないでしょうに
喧嘩によってお互い苦しい思いをするだけであって
だから理屈で生きているならば
人間はかなり幸せに生きているはずなんです
しかし 一人の人間も理性で論理で理屈で生きていないので
みんな動物と同じく ただの感情で人間は生きているんです
だから信仰確立している人
初めて論理的になるんです
信仰確立するためにはそう簡単じゃないんです
うん そういうわけでお釈迦様は真理に基づいて矛盾なく
私は世の中で何の矛盾もなく生きているのです
そこで 田んぼを耕すと仕事終わったらもう気分良くなるでしょ
一生懸命朝 もう大体午前中ですからね
そういう仕事をするのは
午前中パーッとやって
まあ昼ご飯食べて それで仕事終わりという
牛たちを全部介護してあげて
道具を畳んで まあ楽しくご飯食べて
みんなと歌って踊って
まあ家に帰るという 昔の人っていうのは頭悪かったでしょうね
あれ 難しい仕事をでもすごい楽しんでやっていたんだから
日本人と比べると頭悪いでしょうね
日本人っていうのはものすごく緊張してないと
神経ガリガリすり減ってないと
もう病院に運ぶはめにならないと仕事できたようにならんだからね
一時間でできる仕事でも一週間かけてやらないと
それまた徹夜までやってたりして
まあインドは今の方なんです
すごくいい加減で もう一日中ふざけて仕事してくるんです
これ  IT 関係のエンジニアたちはもうほとんどインド人がおってますけどね
そっちから見ると こいつは本当に IT エンジニアでしょうか？と思うぐらいもういい加減で仕事してるんです
いい加減ということではなくて
まあお母さんからすごい立派なエンジニアのお母さんに生まれてもらったりとかね
家にもものすごい給料でしょう
日本人よりは遙かに十倍ぐらい給料もらって
家にいたらお母さんに怒られるわ
で 何のことなくもう で
楽しく生活できるんですよ
まあかなりリラックスして
しかし 競争するところにしっかり競争する
まあだからまあそれ あの仕事と踊り歌っていうのは昔一体でしたからね
鍛冶屋さんには鍛冶屋さんの歌がありまして
みんなに自分の歌踊りあるんです
田んぼを作る人々いうのは
田んぼでやる踊りも歌もありまして
それで畑やる人々いうのはその畑の歌ありまして
それで牛で生活してる人々いうには
まあその牛を飼ってる人
いわゆる牛を飼って牛は仕事をしますからね
あの車を引いたりとかね
荷物運んだりとかね で
その人たちはそれなりの歌があったりして
自分の国ではあるんですよ
伝統的な国の伝統的な歌といえば
これはもうあの従者の人の歌とかね
これはなんだらかんだら貴族の歌とかね
そういうふうにも分けてありますよ
日本では地方の名前でね
民謡ありますけど まあ仕事別にはどうかなと
わかりません 私はあまり日本の民謡は
民謡っていうのは一応仕事とかなり密接に絡んでます
まあそれっていうのは楽しく仕事をしていたんだっていう意味なんですよ
我々インド舞踊と知ってるのは
それ別々ではないんですよ
インド舞踊っていうのは
このバラモン人がこの神様を讃えるために
というか神様を褒め称えるために使っている踊りなんですね
キリスト教の賛美歌みたいに
それが西洋にはかなわないほど踊り文化ができてますよ
音楽もものすごい優れていて
このインド音楽っていうのはかなりクラシック音楽と違ってというのは
この神様に関わる歌なんですね
だから神様に朝早くお祈りする時の歌
もう昼お祈りする時の歌
午後お祈りする時なんか
夜お祈りする時の歌とかね
そのその神々っていうのはもう複数無数にいるんだからね
そのその神に踊る踊りはまたそれぞれ違うし
そうなってくるとかなり芸術文化っていうのは発展していきますよ
それで私たち世界的にインド文化
インド舞踊 インド音楽とか知ってるのは
この一般人の庶民の音楽じゃないんです
庶民の踊りでもないんです
あの こういうヒンドゥー教のお寺でやってる踊りなんですね
それで このとにかく農業やると
まあこの仕事を終わる時のあのほっとした気分っていうのは大変ありがたいんです
まあ普通のどんな人にでも
まあ仕事終わって早く終わって
ではご飯でも食べましょう
お茶でも飲みましょうという
この仕事を終了してね
その時はかなり気分がいいんですよ
この何かやったという
仕事が終わりましたというのは
もう大変だからね 仕事は
これは瞑想する時でも同じことで
瞑想はしっかりやってると
これ大変な作業です で
終わっ まあじゃあこれで終わりますって言ったら
すごい気分良くなるはずですけどね
そういう顔一度見たことないんですけど
[終始背景音楽]もう仕事をしないでほっと仕事をしているんだからね
それはサボるってことなんですよ
もう会社に行っても まずコーヒーを飲むと
それから新聞を読むと
それからタバコ一服そうと
それからトイレ見ると
で 帰ってきたら昼ご飯の時間と
じゃあ昼ご飯に行くそうと
それ以上悪い人っていうのはね
完全に仕事をサボってるでしょうね
その人には一日中ぎっしり仕事をして
仕事を今日は頑張りましたという
あの充実感がないんです
みんな見事に気を騙され
騙したという気分だけでしょうね
まあ瞑想したっても同じ仕事だからね
それはもうサボっちゃうとね
いい気分になるでしょうね
それで このお釈迦様の修行で得られるこのいい気分という
この まあこの充実感というか
あのホッとした気持ちは何なのかと
ソーラッチャンメーパモーじゃな
自分がこの自己管理できる自分を落ち着いた人間になってしまっているんですよ
ヴィパッサナー瞑想をやってみたら
1時間ちゃんとやると
1時間終わると なんだこれ自分がもう人格ができてるんだとわかるんです
1時間で なんか自分人格変わってるんだと
そんな長い時間ももう 130年計画だってやる必要ないんです
これ 1時間しっかり頑張るぞと思って頑張ればいいんです
すごい そうか しっかり頑張るはものすごくきついんです
牛は覚えたくないんだからね
妄想からはもう脱したくないんです
いくら苦しくても 妄想して見栄張りたいんですね
一番悪い さっきの悪い妄想っていうのは
私はこれではダメだと思っているんだ
しっかりしなくちゃいけないんだと思ってるんだ
みんなに迷惑をかけてはいけないと思ってるんだ
なんとかして自分をなんとかならないのかと思っているんだとかね
それは全然治りません
思ってるだけだからね
だって妄想やめろってことも言えないでしょうに
純粋に私はダメな人間だからとかね
あるいはもうみんなのあの人のことで
この人のことで 私はもうこうこう思ってる
こんなことやというと
妄想はそのまま出しますからね
そういう場合はなんか気付けていることはできますけどね
私は瞑想してしっかりした人間になりたいと思っているんだとかね
いう人はもう もうアウト
どうにもならん アクセスする場所がないんです
だから厳しく言う人にも言わせないように
さらに妄想でこの妄想殻を硬くするんです
残念なことこれ仏教の世界では全部読め取れるんですよ
何のことなく それはもう指導させないように喋ってるんだと
その知恵は要りません
妄想で十分だからね 私にアドバイスできないように喋るってことには全然知恵が要りません
どうせ悪魔の世界だからね
それアドバイスできないように喋ると
当然アドバイスできません
明確に時間というのは無駄なんですね
とにかくこの修行っていうのはかなり大変できついものなんですけど
1時間でもやってみたら
なんか自分がそれなりに自己制御したっていうことは経験できるし
自分が変わったっていうこともわかるんですよ
はい 今までの生き方とは違う
なんか見方が変れば生き方変わりますからね
見方が変わったっていうことはわかるんですね
そこはね 自分が自己管理できたら
まあもう大丈夫 もう興奮しない
これからは これからは嫉妬で怒りでも苦しまない
これからは夫婦喧嘩はしない
あんたバカバカしい ということで
何のことなく自分変わってるわけです
それがホッとするところなんです
ああ 頑張りました 次にウィリアンメードラドーラヤン
ウィリアン 精進すること
私は大師やってますよ
ドゥラドーラ ドゥラっていうのは何かやると決めたことですよ
[終始背景音楽]で 会社でもいろいろ仕事を与えるでしょうに
自分に 自分のあなたこれやりなさいと
で そうやって我々は自分の宿題やるんですね
それがウィリアム精進するんですよ
もう見えない とにかく結果出す
宿題しなさいと言ったらしっかり宿題をする
もう言い訳はしません
だから言い訳は面白いこと持ってくるもんだからね
こちらで瞑想して まあ今日は例えばもう新潟の方で大きな地震が起きた
だから新潟で大きな地震が起きたんだからね
今日はちょっと瞑想できなかったとかね
それぐらいでももっとひどい言い訳言うんですよ
私はあんまり瞑想なんかやったことはないんだからと
瞑想やったことないということを言い訳っていうのは
永久的にできないっていう意味でしょうに
よくのこのことそういう理屈言うんですよ
だから言い訳になりたじゃない
体質で弱いんだからとか
まだまだ若いんだからとか
あるいは年だからとか
体が硬いんだからとか
いろんなことを言う ほんと正直に瞑想なんかやりたくないと言えばいいでしょうし
そう言ったらこちらの苦労必要も初めからなくなったわけで
そこで無常なくなるでしょうに
で こちらに聞いて言い訳を言うこと自体でもものすごい無常でしょうに
ですから精進ということ
会社に行ったら仕事を頼んだら
それはもうどんな馬鹿にできるんだったら人を雇う必要ないでしょうに
お金払って仕事をきついんだから会社辞めたと
そうやって自分が人間だと思ってるんですかねと私思いますけど
それでそうやって腰抜けで仕事辞める人がものすごく自慢話するんですよ
例えば何のことなく毎日会社に行っても退職するまで仕事して
あの連中はね バカじゃないかと
何も文句言わずに仕事してるんだと
私は なんかきつい仕事だから辞めましたと
今何？今仕事はないんだと
これ自慢になる話じゃないんだけどね
でも自慢だと思ってるんですよ
だから理屈使ってないんです
きっと言葉の理屈を使わないんですね
だから何でも難しいんですよ
世の中 大変疲れますよ
家のお子さんがまあ洗濯するって洗濯も大量だからね
そんなにもういい加減に怠け者でできるわけじゃないんです
もう買い物をしなくちゃいけない
洗濯もしなくちゃいけないし
掃除機もかけなくちゃいけないし
だからビシビシビシビシそういう仕事をしなくちゃいけないんでしょうに
きついんだから辞めたっていうことは答えでしょうかね
それってもう完全にもう
らない もうもう病気も無分ももういいところなんです
感情もいいところなんです
ですからディリジェンスという精進というか
努力するっていうことが確実に避けられない必要なものなんです
だからお釈迦様が決めたことは結果出るまで諦めないんですね
それどういうことか それが自慢するところは堂々自慢してしまいますよ
私はお釈迦様は解脱するんだ
涅槃涅槃を体験する 苦しみをなくすんだぞと
まず私が苦しみをなくすんだぞと決めたんだから
苦しみがなくすまで頑張った
最初は人いうことを何でもやってみたんです
これしたら苦しみがなくなりますよ
ああそうですか じゃあやってみるぞと
やってみるんです やる時は先生よりもやるんです
まだ文句言えないように
先生も私にはそこまでできませんよと
教えた先生も あんたはギリギリまでやってますよ
そしたらそもそも何のことなく
というわけで ギリギリまでやっても何の成長もないということは
この道では成長がないということですから
ではさようならと出ていくんです
別なところに行ったらまた別な教えが出る
それで年間の苦行をしたんですよ
それでも諦めなかったんです
年間無駄でしたけどね
でもお釈迦様 それ無駄に取らなかったんです
苦行することは それで自分がものすごく精進するもので
言ったことは完璧にやるんだと
それお釈迦様それ買い取るんですよ
苦行で 精神的には全然成長してない
煩悩はそのまま それを教えるんです
苦行中は 煩悩は表れてこなかったんですけど
現れるはずもないですよ
あれほど断食やらいろんな苦行やってますからね
しかし心は清浄するということはなかった
ということで 回の死にかけたし
だから死んでもやりますというくらいの精進で
覚悟でやっていましたけど
だから諦めなかったんです
それでも とにかく発見しますと
ということで リリアンミードやドーライマン
ズラっていう宿題をきちんと結果出るところまで私は精進しましたと
ヨーガッケーマーディワーハナヨーガッケーマー修行の終了
はい 修行を終了しましたと言えるところまで自分が諦めなかったと
いわゆる解脱するまで諦めなかったというところです
それでガッチャティアニワッタンタンヤッタガンターナソーチェリ
ですから 私はもう戻ることない境地に達しているんだ
いわゆる衰えること 堕落することのない境地に達しているんだと
ヤッタガンその境地は何の悩み苦しみもない境地である
これは涅槃のことを言うんですね
涅槃に達したら もうそれでそれからはまた降下することはないんです
エワメーサーカシイカッターそのような耕し方だと
私の場合は それでサーホーティアマタッカラ
私は最初に刈り取るもみっていうんですか
稲っていうのはアマタッムシ
不死ということであれば
いわゆる涅槃ということである
死を乗り越えるんだと
エータンカシンカシットワーナ
私のカシッっていうのは農業のことで
私の農業によってサッバドゥッカカムニケ
すべての苦しみがなくなるんだと
あなたなんかのわけでお腹のご飯食べるだけですよという感じ
それは言ってないんですけどね
俗世間で一生懸命もう田んぼを耕してますけど
結局は食べる米があるだけで終わっちゃうんです
食べるものが食べ終わった後
また食べなくちゃいけないんだから終わりがないんだと
まあ当然食べるものあると苦しみは減ってますよ
食べるものがないと苦しいんだからね
でもそんな苦しみ減ることでは減らないんだと
また食べなくちゃいけないですよね
また田んぼを耕さなくていけないんですよね
終わりないんですよ 私の田んぼの耕しはそうじゃないんだと
全ての苦しみが最終的に終わりますよと
いうことで 田んぼの農業やり方に合わせて
その道具に合わせて仏教の真理修行方法をそのバラモン人に教えてあげたんです
それでバラモン人がお釈迦様を愚痴りたかったんで
あんたただで食うんじゃないよっていうことを
お釈迦様はあんたの農業って何やと
全然意味がないじゃないかと
私こそ本当の百姓です
本当に田んぼを耕してますよ
それで私は獲得する結果はそれで終わりやと
すべて苦しみがなくなるんだと
それにはもう牛が動いてくれませんから
サティという言葉で牛を殴ってますよ
ぶちあてろってことで
つっついてこと 怠けの心をね
ビシビシ殴ってますよ
でも違う それで田んぼの泥がね
ぐちゃぐちゃって それで森林に自信があるという種をまいている
生きることは苦であるということが真理でしょ
苦から脱却しなくちゃいけないという種をまく
それから智慧がわかった
精進がりますとかね まあだから精進と智慧とサティがあれば
まあまた道徳ですね それは戒律とは戒律
体を戒めて征服する 言葉を戒めているというところが戒律のこと
全部仏道を完全にそのまとめて語ったんです
だから誰が本当に仕事してるのかということで
ブッダが本職をやってるんだと
副作業じゃないんだと
副業じゃないんだと 本職
と言ったら バラモン人には言うことはないんですね
まあそれってすごいと思うしかないんですと
自分の主観で人を馬鹿に取るんじゃないんだよ
そのバラモンが思ったのは
ただ仕事して食っちゃえば
それこそ立派な人だからだよと
そんなこと誰でもやってやってますからね
野生の動物も仕事して食べてますけど
もう自慢取るんですかね
それだったら私は生まれた時からずっと呼吸してるんだって自慢すればいいでしょうに
誰でもやってること自慢にならんでしょうに
なんで人は仕事自慢するのかって
私にはちょっとまあわからないんですよ
それだったら私は呼吸してるんだとかね
喉が渇いたら水を飲んでるんだとか自慢すればいい
眠くなったら私は寝ますよとかね
石鹸で体を洗ってるんだとかね
自慢することいっぱいあるでしょうに
なぜ仕事自慢するんですかね
誰でもやってることですね
しかしそれもできないと言ってるんだから
自慢できるところじゃないので
だからまあ生きることは苦であるとね
初めから 感覚は苦であるでしょうし
感覚で生きるでしょうに
その上感覚を発見できるんですよね
我々は歩いたり座ったり
仕事をしたり 勉強したり
料理作ったり 買い物して
生きてるでしょうに それは苦しいんですよ
一つも楽じゃないんです
だから大変だ もうやりたくないんだと言うならば
もう人間というか 普通の動物にも勝てっこはないんです
動物でも苦しいと思わないでしょうね
テレビで見てください
ライオンやらもうどれやら
もう狩りやる時どれほど苦しみますかと
一番スピードある動物はなんでしたっけ？あれ
チーター 足が速いんだから簡単に獲物取れるでしょ
そうじゃないんです 時速四十六十キロで走るのに獲物は取れませんよ
何回何回何回何回頑張って
1日目はもうだいたいお腹がもうものすごく減った時
狩りに行くんです もうこれ以上はもう我慢できない
もう食べなかったらもう飢え死にになるぞというところで
チーターがもう獲物を取るんですよ
じゃあ朝ご飯食べたんだから
じゃあ昼ご飯に一匹と
またそれはないんです
昼ご飯一匹食べましたし
それから夜だったらじゃあ夜の餌を取るとかね
それはないんですよ 人間よりすごい立派な生き方
獲物一匹取ったんだから
これ食べてギリギリまでいるんです
次の日は全く行かない
その次の日も行かない
1週間ぐらい もうそれで
もうお腹が減って もうもうぐちゃぐちゃになったところで
まあこれ以上はもう 飢え死にになるぞというところで
もう獲物を狩りに行くんです
それでも１日  2日  3日頑張って
やっと一匹倒せますからね
だから人生はもう頭が悪いんだから
理屈がないんだから そういう世界見えないんですよ
だから論理性 理性 何のためにあるのかと
それはまあ幸福を壊すために使ってますからね
大量破壊兵器作るような感じで
原子爆弾組み立てるような感じで
科学者なら原子爆弾作りましょうと
知識ってのはそんなために使うもんですかね
だからちょっと中学生前
中学校まで勉強したら
もうもうお手上げ もう人間で終わっちゃうんです
どんないいことにも反動するために
その知識を使うんです
親孝行しないために使うんです
仕事しないために作るんです
使うんです あれって 人間のはすごいまあ批判するべき態度なんですよ
ああ ということでね まあちょっと論理的に世の中見てみると
チーターも大変ですし
ライオンも大変でしょうし
それで草食べてるガサガサ鹿やらね
もうシマウマやらね これまた大変でしょうし
一匹の動物はもう楽々に生きるっていうことはありえないもの
そこでものすごいひどい目にあってるでしょ
皆様に飼われている犬猫は
餌くれてるんだから楽でしょうか？と
逆でしょう ものすごく苦しんでる
自由がなくて 餌くれるんだから機嫌取らなくちゃいけないし
なんで動物誰かの機嫌取る必要あるんでしょうかね
っていうもう飼ってしまえばどうしようもないでしょうね
逃げられませんから  それで追って行っちゃうと手を出しちゃうし
お座りって言っちゃうと座って見せるし
しかしもうもうビシビシともう野原で走り回らないとね
気持ち悪いでしょ これはできない
散歩に連れてのも あれつなげて人間が歩くんだから
人間が歩く足で行っても散歩になりませんだから
ですから 動物 1匹でも楽にいるっていうことはないんです
人間が楽に生活するとたくらんでもね
それはなりたちませんよ
それが矛盾なんです それの言ってることとやってること正反対ですから
何一つも楽になってるのかと
だから頭の悪い科学者やら技術屋さんたちがね
あれこれと作っても作っても
結局はさらにもう難しくなるだけ
そういうわけで では苦しみを全部根絶するそうと思ったら
それは楽にやりたいっていうのはどういう意味ですかね
家賃払うために 三食食べるためにどれぐらい苦労してるのかと
ただ三食食べて家賃払ってるだけでしょうに
仕事したってね 大したお金残らないでしょうに
それにどれぐらい苦労するのかと考えてないんですよ
やっぱり自己育ててないんだから
だから瞑想も瞑想なんて
それはちょっともう楽にやりたいと
では成り立たない 楽じゃない
そういうわけだから この諦めないことをね
精進するということが必要になります
それでお釈迦様の仕事をすると
サッバドゥッカパムンティ
一切の苦しみから脱出することはできると
一切の苦しみから脱出すれば
それでもうやることはない
だからお釈迦様が仕事は修行は終了しましたというところまで諦めざるを得ましたと
それでもうちゃんともう買い取りしているんだと
結果を だからお釈迦様は堂々と私もちゃんと田んぼを耕して生活しているのだとはっきりと言っている
[背景音楽]